Let's go next to our call there from the nine
five four area code nine five four has been
holding on for a little while.
Who's this?
Where are you calling from?
It's me.
Yes, it is.
What's it, David?
It's actually Sebastian calling in from Miami.
Great.
What's going on?
Well, I want to first start by saying that
to this day, I love your show.
I actually was the right winger who called
in a few months ago asking for career advice
for anyone listening.
That video is still up if you want to go check
it out.
So do you remember that or.
I don't.
I'm sorry.
No, it's all right, you got a bunch of calls,
but I think today's question is going to be
a lot more straightforward, OK?
I have a few, but let's just see how many
I could get in here.
So, as you may know, Khania has announced
his bid for presidency this week.
You know, previously we saw his relationship
with Trump.
It's a positive.
So really, you know, I might just some kind
of weird question, but I have this this kind
of like underlying feeling that it might be
some type of Trump administration strategy
to absorb that crucial black bow.
You know, would that just be nonsense?
I mean, you're not the first person to bring
this up to me.
The idea would be Trump and cognac, your friends.
Joe Biden right now has 92 percent from black
voters.
What better way to hurt Biden than by having
a black, prominent black entrepreneur and
musical artist run and take a little bit of
the black vote from Biden?
That so?
So the motive would certainly be there.
I think what it misses is that I don't believe
black folks are going to vote for Konya who
were otherwise going to vote for Biden.
There may be Connew fans who weren't even
planning to vote.
Remember, half the country doesn't vote who
I guess might vote for Konya, even though
he's still, as far as I know to this day,
he's not formally running anywhere.
He just said he's running.
But I think that it's fundamentally, you know,
insulting and dismissive of the black community,
too.
If that's your plan, to imagine that the black
community is just going to vote for any black
guy who who runs is not borne out by the evidence.
And I think it's it's a bad strategy if that's
the strategy.
Yeah, I also heard that he's missed some crucial
deadlines, so I don't even think it would
be possible if it comes down to it.
Would you actually ever consider voting cognac
over Trump?
I guess you could.
You would probably be anything other than
Trump.
Yeah, I mean, I don't know about that.
You know, it's it's not occurred to me that
that's ever a position I would be in.
So I'm going to opt out of even answering
that.
But I am no fan of Konya.
He seems extremely unstable.
I mean, over Trump, it's like it's hard to
justify voting for Trump over anyone.
That'll be a tough one.
I don't know what I would do.
OK, let me just see if you can answer this
one.
Ghislaine Maxwell, she was just arrested and
indicted.
And from what I heard yesterday, she has like
a bargaining chips, which is supposedly a
bunch of videos, pictures or whatever that's
incriminating.
A lot of public figures and influencers.
Do you have any idea of some of the names
we might be seeing in your future?
I have absolutely no idea.
I'm not going to put the cart before before
the horse on that.
And I am waiting to see if and what comes
of it.
And I've also not read the allegations that
you're citing.
All right, Sebastian, I've got a lot of people
holding, so I'm going to move on.
I'm it sounds like you had a litany of questions,
but I'm going to move on set to make sure
some other folks get an opportunity.